,
LESS PEOPLE CROSS, LESS PEOPLE
DIE.
LESS VULNERABLE PEOPLE PUTTING
THEIR HANDS IN THE CRIMINAL
ORGANIZATIONS WHO DON'T GIVE A
DAMN ABOUT THESE PEOPLE.
JUST A WAY TOE MONEY.
THAT'S WHY KEEP GOING BACK AND I
TALK ABOUT SECURING THE BORDER.
PRESIDENT TRUMP WAS THE GREATEST
PRESIDENT IN MY LIFETIME WHEN IT
COMES TO THE BORDER SECURITY
BECAUSE HE SAVED LIVES BY
SECURING THE BORDER.
THIS ADMINISTRATION CAME IN AND
PURPOSEFULLY UNSCIEWRLD IT AND
NOW WE SEE THE RESULTS.
THOUSANDS OF AMERICANS ARE
DYING.
WE GOT OVER 700 MIGRANT DEATHS.
NOW ANOTHER 46.
IT'S DISGUSTING.
AND THAT'S WHY NIGHTMARE.
>> Brian: THAT'S WHY MAYORKAS --
YOU COULD IMPEACH HIM BUT THE
NEXT PERSON IS GOING TO BE JUST
AS BAD BECAUSE IT ALL COMES FROM
PRESIDENT BIDEN.
HE DOES NOT CARE.
AND IF HE CARED, MAYORKAS
WOULD -- IT DOESN'T MATTER.
YOU WILL COULD HAVE THAT JOB,
TOM, THEY WOULDN'T LET YOU DO
IT.
YOU WOULD HAVE TO QUIT.
>> I UNDERSTAND THAT.
THIS IS ALL JOE BIDEN HE RAN ON
OPEN BORDERS.
HE SIGNED OVER 90 EXECUTIVE
ORDERS BASICALLY ABOLISHING
EVERYTHING FROM THE TRUMP
ADMINISTRATION.
>> Brian: NUTS.
>> AMERICAN PEOPLE NEED TO STAND
UP AND RAISE HELL.
PEOPLE ARE DYING.
WE HAVE TO STOP THE MADNESS.
>> Ainsley: I DON'T KNOW WHY
THEY GET IN THE BACK OF THESE
TRUCKS.
I SEE SO MANY VIDEOS OF LINES OF
PEOPLE JUST WALKING THROUGH THE
RIO GRANDE, WALKING ACROSS INTO
AMERICA.
THEY DON'T EVEN NEED A TRUCK.
TOM, IT'S JUST HEART BREAKING.
>> BECAUSE THESE PEOPLE DON'T
WANT TO BE ARRESTED.
THEY ARE PAYING THE CRIMINAL
CARTELS.
THEY KNOW THEY MAY GET ARRESTED.
THEY WANT TO GET AWAY.
SMUGGLER TAKE A PICKUP TRUCK AND
SMUGGLE 12.
OR TRACTOR-TRAILER AND SMUGGLE 8
THEY WILL MAKE A LOT OF MONEY.
THEY DON'T CARE IF THEY PUT THEM
IN A STEEL BOX WITH NO AIR
CONDITIONING.
THEY CARE ABOUT THE MONEY.
CRIMINAL ORGANIZATIONS ARE
ANIMALS.